you
everyone is Jerry I just got paired up
here against a Stefan it's a five minute
time control game right through a couple
seeks out 1432 and the other four five
so here we are with a 50 game so let's
see how this plays out no increment so I
cannot lean on the increment here let's
let's push grab some space and okay
let's support my Center so I want to
hopefully have this pond be a bit of a
thorn and this night's journey will
probably be into that c4 square hmm how
to play this now I could go forward with
efore or Bishop f4 and then III I want
to take that approach yeah Bishop Bishop
here III and then Knight d2 still so
let's meet a 6 with a 4 and is there a
reason to not play III right now um I
don't think so so this is a bit more of
a conservative approach I won't have to
worry of my epon coming under fire so I
think just Bishop to e2 right now or
actually I think h3 let me consider yeah
i'm going to insert this move first each
three this rules out any Bishop g4 and
on Bishop f5 okay I'm Bishop f5 I think
I was going to play Knight d2 in fact I
think it's important i play Knight d2
right now
I wonder if I've already misplayed this
may be Bishop d3 in fact they should be
three because I don't want to allow this
night to so easily move because then I
have to contend with the bishop so and I
better I better start hustling no
increment and I'm down a minute and a
half so let's let's speed up here and
get castled soon ooh okay so they're
really insisting i'm going to go for
that and okay he has double isolated
pawn so this can't be so great as
trouble moving the night i'm expecting
94 and i think we need to is a nice
solid approach isn't that just dropping
upon or am i missing Oh Bishop takes a
t69 b6 although then I get c5 what's the
story with that I guess it's one of
those just move quick and then show me
what the what the big trick is okay
there's the big trick double attack
against bishop and be too alright so
let's get out of the way I'm going to be
losing my be to pond but uh maybe I
could be playing work to be one at some
stage right have to move my knight first
or do I Queen d3c for that's a bit
annoying hmm
okay i'm going to i'm going to
reposition my night and if he gets to
that at five square that's going to be
one beast of a piece a Knight takes pawn
I could recapture and then beyond this
guy's let's play thats Queen takes rook
was being threatened I'm ready to scoop
up that beep on and again don't forget
about my night one day maybe getting to
f5 I do take here it is with tempo
against the night how bad can that
really be we're going to find out he's a
passed pawn hmm why not push them let's
run just a little bit i have my queen
and my rook that could be defending the
square and maybe even a night on e5
should i do that right now my queen is
tied down to the defense of my night two
minutes let's push this might be an ID
at some stage Bishop c7 uh-huh
threatening my bishop
ok
what about night H for now hmm let's see
Bishop that easily Bishop here let's
remove their dark square Bishop
yeah I think I like that let's get rid
of their dark square Bishop in 239 hmm
oh my night getting into this square
will be deadly we're going to see what
stock fish has to say after this I have
to be careful of c3 certainly two pieces
converging on that score I have enough
defense
of course it would free up my my queen
to do some other things if I don't have
to know I don't have to watch over my
night on e 2 i'd be really nice so night
here i would just take at some point and
then my queen is free to do some other
exciting things so this can't be too
comfortable right my brooke isn't so
accessible maybe night d6 Bishop takes
Knight takes Knight d6 seems a bit fishy
that might be an idea three-minute
warning for Team black ship takes Knight
takes Knight d6 what would i do on that
my rook is hit maybe huh it's kind of
tough not quite sure I might as well
pre-move that or no well they're going
to play 96mm oh they didn't play 96 very
surprising i think i should move in
for wat nie g3 was my first thought is
there something better yes there is
knight c6 right away
you
no let's not do that let's go here so
that if Knight takes Knight I could
recapture my night is cemented into e
five minute nine okay I was forgetting
the Queen was defending the night
initially I thought knight c6 and after
a couple captures I could take the night
here not the case okay Queen d6 looks
really active hitting the night
hmm something better no no no let's go
here she's she's doing a lot feels like
it's close to mate No
clean here
it's really active
Queenie seven
Wow
really
huh
I shouldn't have to retreat I have to
defend f2 okay they're gone for a queen
trade man i know i should have had
something better my Brooke is going to
get kicked I'm going to try to be a pest
hand my pond and my pond is what
floundering at this point off lost the
thread here for sure that's going to run
into a fork I should have had more 19
seconds let's see if I can maybe scoop
up that pond okay oh there goes my night
they missed it minute 15 to 2 minutes
gonna back off I could get that pun
they're not going to let me get that
pond i could give this check
probably preme of that not quite sure
where I should be going
right right here is pretty good now give
a check 11 seconds yeah bad time
management to hmm
I should probably look to break down or
even get in here with my king this would
be an interesting end game if I had more
time but I spent too much time trying to
trying to do what actually I should just
take the night if that happens
hmm looking good
okay i'm on the night I'm really
foundering I should have given a check
five seconds get my king up I should
have pushed now I could push next maybe
get my king up Oh for a drow he going on
time clearly but this should be it
should be a drop maybe he's the one who
has to worry about point three and I
have to guess
no off okay well let's uh put this into
stock fish and see what it has to say
about this one okay let's see where we
could improve that final position was it
should be a draw but I very very poor
time management and I spent I feel like
I spent too much time I clearly spend
too much time trying to find some nakao
in the middle game so this is a fine set
up what I'm going for here just to give
you a feel evaluation wise it's around a
half pond advantage and it doesn't like
Bishop f5 that was my initial impression
but I clearly didn't take advantage of
this okay take stakes 94 is being called
for huh you know what move I missed
right here is one that's probably just
flat-out winning saying plus two not
with taking the pond but rather night h5
you know when did I rear ended when did
I recognize that this was I think only
after the Queen came down to be 21 see I
took the pawn the Queen get down here
only when I moved my night here was I
starting to think about f5 you know this
is this is what I'll often do when I'm
just to share my train of thought with
with how I'll look to improve from blitz
games or just any games really over the
board games I'll question the timing of
when I was thinking about certain moves
why in this case was I not thinking
about this f5 square a little bit
earlier I mean I could be saying that to
myself right away as soon as I take the
bishop I might as well just reassess the
black king side of the board blacks
kingside quadrant and recognize the
weaknesses this is a glaring weakness I
only said I kinda only said to my
and I didn't voice it but I i thought
you know okay these double isolated
pawns but I for some reason I just
wasn't focused on getting to f5 f5 we
can now consider a hole and I could hop
right to it and jump on that square
Queen c2 is another move here but
certainly after castles 97 the computer
likes night h4 with plus 2 and you
really can't deal with a night on
ellfive can you what this is the the
best to take on d5 I guess we're going
to have me being up the exchange in this
variation with 97 to follow but hopping
right to that at five square hmm which I
saw that much sooner this still has
about a pond plus advantage 92 still
upon plus advantage rookie one it's
approaching plus two yeah with d6 to
follow that's fine and now night h4
instead of pushing something was lost
with that push here mmm another I wonder
how else I could view this position
instead of pushing the pond because my
bishop is a pretty good defender maybe
maybe the one defender I would like to
have instead of time I work down to the
defense although this is quite natural
to just continue to push it once again
is looking to jump into that age
Foursquare and for a bit I was thinking
that I would like to put my night to g3
and then get too into f5 but I was a bit
blind to just this night as well hopping
to f5 and two moves both of these guys
are on same color square so they could
probably both maneuver to that at five
square and just two moves mmm
okay so night h4 was once again being
called out for with about a two and a
half point advantage I pushed still
maintains an advantage it should be five
is what it likes recapture it's at plus
three now and then knight c6 I thought
knight c6 ah why didn't I go this is
plus five nights e6 rook takes rook
takes Knight takes oh I can take the
knight on d5 that's as far as my
calculation went I didn't realize that I
have this fork at the end mmm that's the
one thing that was keeping me from this
I even said it during the game I was
like oh no i forgot the Queen was
defending that night I didn't I
calculate that well at the end I had 97
ah what a missed opportunity this is
still winning the whole time
it's plus 6 plus 8 it's a matin 40 no
night h5
what did i do I retreated this is still
plus 3 but night h5 is a game over move
oh and so many missed opportunities with
this made on g7 you don't stop that made
in three that's painful I retreated
still plus 3 plus 2 now I do not each
for so much later it's still winning and
brooke one takes e4 is what it wants to
do Knight takes e4 night takes f5
that's that's tough to do especially
with what time I had left this is this
is was on had me at an advantage the
whole while like until this ending here
as soon as I took now it just it's a
tremendous shift this ending should have
been too bad it's back to yeah they
could have taken my night here they took
the pawn you know this is an even ending
but yeah the time really got the best of
me at this point plenty of missed
opportunities with this one but I didn't
do well enough to manage my time that's
for sure and yeah the final position no
it's even liking white a little bit but
yeah not not a good one here for our
clock management that's for sure takes I
should have been quicker with the
multiple premiums there but this was the
final position I lost here so okay as
usual feel free to leave any comments in
the comment section below and I'll catch
in the next video take care bye
you